à toutes et à tous donc nous poursuivons
nos travaux avec une table ronde qui est
consacrée au matériaux biosourcés pour
l'isolation donc nous recevons ainsi les
représentants de trois organismes ou 4
3 d'accord 3 organismes l'association
des industriels de la construction
biosourcée et représentée par son
président Monsieur Olivier jorot votre
association représente les industries
françaises produisant des matériaux à
destination du marché de la construction
à partir de ressources renouvelables
elle mène plusieurs actions comme la
rédaction de règles professionnelles de
mise en oeuvre des isolants fibres
végétales et la mise en place d'études
sur les produits de construction
biosourcée l'association construire en
chambre représentée par Monsieur
Philippe Lamarque son président
l'association mène des actions de
promotion de l'usage du chanvre pour les
bâtiments et elle a noué des
partenariats avec de nombreuses
entreprises comme agrochambre
interchange
le réseau français de la construction
paille qui est représentée par Madame
Coralie Garcia l'association est née en
2006 elle fédère les acteurs de la
filière et participent à la définition
des règles sur la construction paille
j'ai oublié de citer en vous présentant
monsieur le Président votre secrétaire
général qui est à vos côtés monsieur
Yves Hustache donc madame messieurs la
filière des matériaux biosourcés
utilisés en forte croissance en France
en 2020 le volume d'isolation réalisé
grâce à des matériaux biosourcés étaient
équivalents à 84000 maisons
individuelles et ce chiffre représentait
une augmentation de 87% par rapport aux
quatre années qui précédaient
l'utilisation des matériaux biosourcés
présentent en effet plusieurs avantages
ils sont généralement biodégradables
renouvelable et produit en France il
montre de bonnes performances en matière
d'isodation notamment concernant le
confort d'été permettent de réduire les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
enfin peuvent être adaptés pour les
bâtiments qui présentent un intérêt
patrimonial pour toutes ces raisons les
pouvoirs publics ont encouragé le
développement des matériaux biosourcés
la loi du 17 août 2015 relative à la
transition énergétique pour la
croissance verte affirme que
l'utilisation des matériaux biosourcés
est encouragé par les pouvoirs publics
lors de la construction ou de la
rénovation des bâtiments la
réglementation
environnementale pour la construction re
20 20 et favorable au matériaux
biosourcés dans ce contexte quel
jugement portez-vous sur les politiques
menées visant à encourager l'utilisation
des radio biosourcés toutefois les
matériaux biosourcés présentent une
grande diversité
quels sont les matériaux les plus
susceptibles d'être massifiés dans
l'isolation et quels sont ceux dont le
potentiel de développement en France et
le plus important les matériaux
biosourcés continuent également de
susciter des interrogations dans le
débat public l'une des questions
concerne l'usage des sols la culture des
végétaux utilisés pour la construction
pourrait faire concurrence à d'autres
cultures notamment celles destinées à
l'alimentation que pouvez-vous répondre
à cette interrogation
avant de vous laisser la parole pour
répondre à ses premières questions et
pour un propos introductif d'environ
dizaine à quinzaine de minutes mais vous
le gérerez comme vous le souhaitez il me
revient de vous indiquer que cette
audition est diffusée en direct mais
également en différé sur le site
internet du Sénat et qu'elle fera
l'objet d'un compte rendu qui sera
publié je dois également vous rappeler
qu'un faux témoignage devant votre
commission d'arquette et passible des
peines prévues aux articles
434-13
434-14 et 434-15 du code pénal qui
peuvent aller de trois ans à 7 ans
d'emprisonnement et de 45000 euros à
100000 euros d'amende je vous invite
donc si vous le voulez bien à prêter
serment de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité a levé la main droite et à
dire je ne jure commence par vous
peut-être monsieur Eustache
voilà je vous remercie donc je vais vous
laisser la parole et ensuite notre
rapporteur mais aussi les membres de
notre commission d'enquête qui assistent
également à cette audition et que je
remercie pour leur présence seront à
même également de vous poser un certain
nombre de questions alors je ne sais pas
comment vous voulez vous répartir
peut-être monsieur joro vous commencez
merci d'avoir rappelé le développement
des branchez votre micro s'il vous plaît
non ça doit être celui-là
donc merci d'avoir appelé en effet le
tout l'intérêt développement des
matériaux de sourcées qui sont des
matériaux renouvelables alors pas
biodégradables corriger je la
présentation parce que on pourrait
penser qu'ils vont se dégrader dans le
bâtiment ce qui n'est pas le cas ils ont
toutes les caractéristiques pour être
durable dans le bâtiment
donc c'est matériaux qui sont surtout
recyclables en fin de vie et je
reviendrai après donc une fille une
filière qui s'est fortement développée
certaines années autour de matériaux
renouvelables puisqu'on a la chance en
France finalement de pouvoir utiliser
des cops produits
issus de la forêt ou issus de
l'agriculture on en parle tout à l'heure
la question sur l'enjeu potentiel par
rapport à l'alimentation
donc des matériaux qui si finalement on
peut être renouvelables à l'infini et
sur les matériaux quoi un gros un gros
intérêt par rapport au risque
d'épuisement des ressources fossiles en
général il y en a mais on sait qu'à un
moment donné donc autant utiliser
matériaux lorsqu'ils sont renouvelables
ce sont des matériaux qui sont les
coproduits utilisés pour la fabrication
matériaux sur tout le territoire on a
des matériaux disponibles parce qu'on
appelle des des matières des coproduits
issus de la culture ou la forêt
et puis le gros avantage c'est des
matériaux aujourd'hui qui sont pas
importants sont les matériaux qui sont
fabriqués sont de retour je pense que
par rapport à l'enjeu de la souveraineté
on en parle souvent et dans le bâtiment
il convient d'être vigilant on a encore
aujourd'hui beaucoup de matériaux qui
sont importés issus de la chimie
notamment donc voilà tout l'enjeu nos
matériaux ceci des matériaux et par
rapport à l'enjeu énergétique parce
qu'on se pose souvent la question
évidemment la baisse de consommation
énergie long bâtiment mais il y a
l'enjeu la consommation énergétique pour
fabriquer ces matériaux on a l'avantage
avec les matériaux issus des connexes on
va dire que ce soit végétaux ou en tout
cas de l'agriculture on a des matériaux
qui consomment peu d'énergie pour être
fabriqués donc ça c'est aussi un atout
on n'est pas sur des industries qui
émettent énormément de d'énergie pour
les fabriquer je prends des matériaux
comme les nôtres par exemple base de
chanvre ce sont des fours à 140 degrés
pas des fours à 1000 degrés donc on a un
enjeu énergétique et d'ailleurs les F2S
qu'on peut on peut avoir aujourd'hui
dans le bâtiment vous avez fait de la
F2S la fiche déclaration
environnementale sanitaire qui est un
permis de construire la r2020
traduisent très bien aujourd'hui tout
l'intérêt de matériaux par rapport au
stockage carbone Kamen ces matériaux
puisque ces matériaux d'origine végétale
sont des matériaux par la photosynthèse
qui sont des puits de carbone alors ils
ont un impact en fin de vie évidemment
mais la fin de vie c'est dans 40 ans 50
ans au moment où vont utiliser selon
qu'il soit recyclé ou non ils pourront
avoir un impact en rejet de carbone mais
bon c'est une échéance à 40 ans à
l'effet immédiat c'est quand même un
stockage carbone
donc s'il y a trois enjeux majeurs pour
la filière de mathurbe sourcée
dans le cas de la rénovation énergétique
que le sujet sur lequel on est
auditionné aujourd'hui c'est l'enjeu de
la rénovation globale aujourd'hui nous
le bilan qu'on fait c'est qu'il y a une
rénovation qui se fait avant tout
souvent sur des thématiques précises
donc on va changer une chaudière on va
changer les menuiseries et
malheureusement quand lorsqu'on veut
rénover une maison c'est l'enveloppe du
bâtiment qu'il faut traiter et pas
seulement le changement d'une chaudière
même si c'est utile mais nous ce qu'on
voit dans le bilan la prime rénov c'est
qu'une grosse partie est utilisée sur
quelques travaux et on sait que la
rénovation énergétique c'est un peu plus
compliqué et donc là on a voulu aussi
vous faire des propositions l'occasion
de cette audition donc nous il semble
important de conditionner les aides
demain pour être mises en place par
l'État à une maîtrise d'oeuvre experte
dans le cas de la rénovation thermique
du bâtiment comme on le fait aujourd'hui
dans les revins vins et elles
obligations d'être accompagnées par les
architectes au-delà d'une certaine
surface tu as pas une maîtrise d'oeuvre
et aujourd'hui malheureusement la
rénovation énergétique bah il y a pas de
compétences spécifiques hormis l'artisan
qui va traiter de son sujet et je pense
que c'est important que les particuliers
ou les entreprises tertiaires soient
accompagnées par des professionnels
donc favoriser la rénovation globale
après ce qui nous semble également
important
dans le cas d'une loi climat résilience
l'article 39 par l'extérieur de la loi
de transition énergétique médias loi
climat résilience qui prévoit
l'obligation dans le cas de la commande
publique pour les rénovation énergétique
de d'utiliser au moins 25% de matériaux
biosourcés aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de
décret qui était mis en place qui était
il y a pas des traits d'application pour
cet article et on souhaite en tout cas
que c'est 25% de Matthieu de sourcés
donnèration la commande publique puisse
être mise en place progressivement avec
un calendrier de façon Ant donc on
propose nous un calendrier progressif
d'ici 2028 de façon à laisser du temps
et on sait que sur la commande publique
bah là je lance pas le maîtrise d'oeuvre
on est sur des chantiers plus importants
c'est un moyen aussi de mettre en place
des professionnels qui pourront demain
être utilisés également par des
chantiers sur le chantier moins
important notamment les particuliers
après le deuxième enjeu c'est financer
la mastication industrielle ça rejoint
une de vos questions de la filière a
cours et moyen terme pour répondre aux
jeux de rénovation et pas seulement du
neuf aujourd'hui il y a déjà l'industrie
en France donc c'est un peu sont
satisfaire c'est pas le cas de tous les
pays la France est plutôt en avance avec
l'Allemagne donc moi en tant que
président laicb donc c'est pas seulement
l'isolation c'est le match source en
général même si aujourd'hui c'est
beaucoup de familles de l'isolation
nous sommes industriels on va doubler
nos capacités dans les 50 qui viennent
pour répondre à ces enjeux on pourrait
aller plus vite et vous savez c'est la
fois la mastication de l'industrie mais
c'est aussi toute la l'innovation à
faire dans ces industries et plus on a
les moyens plus tu peux avoir des
procédés innovants on est sur des
produits techniques et là aujourd'hui le
constat c'est qu'on a peu
d'accompagnement sur la mastication
industrielle aujourd'hui on accompagne
beaucoup la décarbonation des industries
en place ce qui est une très bonne chose
aussi je trouve qu'il faut accompagner
cette industrie traditionnelle à des
carboner leur industrie mais nous
aujourd'hui on a l'avantage d'avoir des
produits qui stockent du carbone et on a
très peu d'ailes lorsqu'on dépose des
projets pour massifier notre industrie
avec des usines de taille plus
importante et c'est un regret parce que
ce sont beaucoup de PME qui sont
derrière même si maintenant des grands
groupes s'intéressent à ces sociétés
donc c'est une donnée aux demandes et
puis on souhaiterait également pour nous
aider à nous développer on a la Rep qui
s'est mise en place donc la
responsabilité élargie aux producteurs
depuis 1er mai 2023
nous sommes concernés par cette trêpes
alors je dis pas qu'on doit pas être
concerné mais aujourd'hui payer une REP
alors que nos matériaux ne sont pas
amenés à déconstruits vont être
déconstruits dans 20 30 40 ans parce que
les premiers ont été posés il y a une
vingtaine d'années on trouve que c'est
pas très juste par rapport à l'intérêt
général que présente nos matériaux par
le stockage du carbone et on peine
filière alors qu'aujourd'hui voilà on
n'est pas concernés et ça sera un moyen
de nous accompagner pour développer plus
rapidement dans notre filière puisque
évidemment c'est génial des secours
supplémentaires
et puis après si vous avez nous aider
également dans la diffusion de ces
matériaux permettant un accès facilité
aux certifications alors je vais pas
dire qu'on est qu'on a des frais énormes
on en a quand même parce que son nouveau
matériau est malheureusement
les coups pour des industries comme les
nôtres qui sont pas la taille des
grandes industries qu'on peut connaître
dans le bâtiment c'est souvent un frein
donc c'est aussi une demande de
défilières après le troisième enjeu je
finirai par là c'est favoriser
l'utilisation la visibilité des
solutions biosourcées dans le cadre du
nécessaire sobriété énergétique donc il
y a les C2E qui existent depuis
maintenant plusieurs années on voit
qu'il y a des effets beaucoup
d'opportunistes ou sur les C2E puisque
aujourd'hui il y a des quotas de C2E qui
sont pas
on va dire stable dans la durée au
niveau notamment des cumacs donc il y a
des effets d'opportunités selon les
acteurs avec une forte demande parfois
sur l'isolation je pense notamment c'est
fait sur les combles ou les chaudières
on s'aperçoit comme on est il y a un
coup d'arrêt des clés du Max sont des
niveaux inférieurs donc ça amène parfois
une écho délinquance parfois entendu
parler donc nous on souhaite que c'était
fait soit corrigé avec une analysation
des quotas de C2E pour éviter cet effet
qui est de la catastrophique
généralement pour les industries quelles
qu'elles soient je parle pas seulement
pour les matures de sourcer et y compris
pour les artisans parce que derrière il
y a des artisans qui se forment et
malheureusement quand le marché s'arrête
ce sont des artisans qui se retrouvent
sans travail alors qu'ils se sont formés
pour ces applications de rénovation
énergétique et puis on a une demande
également sur les ma prime rénov ces
deux heures on souhaiterait une bonne
éducation pour les matériaux de sourcés
afin d'impulser le stockage carbone dans
l'acte de rénovation
point important qui nous semble
justifier par cet enjeu du stockage
carbone représente nos matériaux c'est
mettre en place une TV réduite sur
l'hématome sourcé pour aider cette
développement de cette filière qui a
intérêt à la fois au niveau du stockage
carbone pour répondre à l'enjeu
la bicarbonation du bâtiment et puis
quel intérêt général pour construire une
industrie qui est comme je vous dis tout
à l'heure souveraine sur son pays
puisque ce sont les matériaux très
difficiles à apporter puisqu'il
évidemment qu'on vous parlait d'économie
circulaire ils doivent être fait sur
place ce qui est le cas de tous les
industries aujourd'hui que je représente
très bien
Madame Monsieur Je sais pas qui commence
bonjour Coralie Garcia donc je travaille
pour le réseau français de la
construction en paille donc nous on a un
modèle un petit peu différent quand même
de l'Association des gens qui font
partie de l'Association des industriels
de la construction biosourcée parce que
on est parti du matériau botte de paille
donc du matériau qui vient directement
du champ donc c'est vrai que vous pouvez
parler juste un peu plus fort au devant
plus le micro merci donc nous on a
commencé à travailler avec le matériau
botte de paille donc il vient
historiquement directement du champ donc
c'est vrai qu'on évite de passer par une
industrie on évite ces transports on
évite aussi de repasser dans une machine
etc et de rajouter des intrants donc
c'est un matériau assez brut
à l'époque ce sont surtout des maisons
individuelles qui ont été construites
aujourd'hui on a de plus en plus de
d'établissements recevant du public des
écoles des crèches des lycées et aussi
des casernes de pompiers entre autres
j'étais à le préciser donc c'est vrai
qu'on a un modèle assez différent on est
une association on regroupe des
professionnels entre autres aussi des
adhérents en particulier des organismes
de formation
mais on a environ 500 entreprises qui
sont adhérentes à notre association et
notre particularité est de faire la
promotion d'un matériau de construction
qu'on transforme en matériaux agricole
et qu'on fait devenir matériaux de
construction grâce à notre savoir-faire
et l'idée là dedans c'est vraiment
d'utiliser ce matériau qui est vraiment
très abondant de la paille ou des
chambres de blé vous en avez vu vous
envoyez dès que vous prenez
la route et donc c'est un matériau qui
est vraiment très abondant là on a fait
un calcul on est en moyenne entre le
champ et le chantier on a environ 50 km
c'est la moyenne du déplacement d'une
mode de paille pour passer de du champ
aux chantiers directement donc c'est
vrai que on n'est pas une industrie de
la construction paille en fait on a
plein de petites industries qui sont
partout dans tous les départements alors
ceux où il y a un peu plus de d'élevage
on ne trouvera un peu plus difficilement
de la botte de paille mais clairement on
en trouvera moins de 100 km sans trop de
difficultés
donc nous pour tout ce qui est
concurrence finalement des sols on n'a
pas trop de problèmes parce que la
ressource est abondante on est
exportateur de paille au niveau européen
et on a calculé pour vous donner un
ordre de grandeur que si tout le marché
du neuf était isolé avec de la paille
c'est pas encore le cas mais si c'était
le cas on utiliserait quand même que 10%
de la paille produite en France donc sur
cette concurrence là on n'a pas trop de
soucis après on regarde quand même les
chaudières à paille qui sont en train de
sortir ça nous attriste un petit peu
quand même de bruit de la paille pour
essayer de chauffer des bâtiments alors
que finalement on pourrait la mettre en
isolant ça éviterait quand même voilà de
brûler des tonnes de paille pour rien
et c'est aussi un sous-produit de
l'agriculture donc on ne plante pas des
champs de blé pour faire de la paille
pour l'isolation on est en plane d'abord
pour faire de la céréale pour pour
l'alimentation
on a commencé notre travail surtout sur
le marché du neuf parce que c'était
le
domaine qu'on connaissait le plus et
depuis quelques années on a essayé de
développer surtout l'isolation par
l'extérieur parce qu'on pense que c'est
l'utilisation de la paille qui est la
plus pérenne
et on a pas mal de chantiers
démonstrateurs mais comme on reste une
association et que on n'est pas des
fabricants on a des ressources
financières assez limitées pourtant on a
des techniques assez prometteuses pour
isoler efficacement nos bâtiments en
sachant que nos bottes de pain et nous
elles font entre 22 cm et 37 cm donc on
n'ira pas faire une isolation de 10 cm
ou 8 qui sera refaire dans 10 ans ou 15
ans nous on part en se disant on fait
une isolation elle va tenir minimum 100
ans c'est d'ailleurs le premier bâtiment
en paille en France date de 1920 donc on
sait on a ce retour là concret une
isolation pas il tient minimum 100 ans
et donc on part comme ça en se disant on
veut de la qualité et une isolation
forte dès le début pour éviter de
refaire des travaux dans 20 ans et c'est
comme ça qu'on a confond de nos
techniques constructives après il nous
manque quand même des aides pour
développer ces techniques parce que
forcément ça demande et du travail
d'écriture de document technique et de
la recherche et de la formation
et aussi sur ce cette problématique de
formation on a de plus en plus de mal à
faire reconnaître les formations qu'on
écrit au niveau de France compétences
donc voilà on a on a écrit plusieurs
formations même avec d'autres filières
biosourcés et c'est toujours compliqué
d'arriver à avoir une réponse il y a
beaucoup de de temps de de retard etc et
ben du coup nous qui voilà on attend on
attend que ce soit validé ou un temps de
pouvoir développer tout ça en sachant
que on a développé une formation il y a
une douzaine d'années il y a plus de
5000 professionnels qui l'ont suivi dont
40% d'architectes donc ça veut dire à
peu près 2000 architectes qui ont suivi
cette formation une formation propyle
formation de 5 jours
et c'est pour ça que ça se développe
beaucoup d'ailleurs dans dans sur la
commande publique donc on a vraiment un
besoin d'avancer là-dessus et on a une
aussi une particularité c'est que comme
on est un isolant qui n'est pas un
isolant certifié qui ne passe pas dans
une usine on souvent les aides sont
conditionnées à avoir un isolant
certifié à céramique et malheureusement
ça c'est c'est écrit un peu partout et
les gens qui gèrent les dossiers ne se
réfèrent qu'à ça et quand les gens
veulent faire une isolation par
l'extérieur en paille il se dès le début
il se bloque ils sont bloqués par ça et
ils ont du mal à avoir des aides donc
c'est un frein supplémentaire et ils ont
du mal à y aller alors que souvent ce
sont des gens qui font quand même des
rénovations globales
lourdes avec changement des fenêtres
isolation de la toiture etc et qui
tendent vers du passif
en tout cas on va vers ça on les
encourageaient vers là donc c'est
vraiment quelque chose qu'on aimerait
qui se développe et surtout de la
qualité de la qualité dans l'isolation
pour que à faire des travaux on les
fasse pas pour les refaire dans le même
temps quoi ça sert à rien
allons-y fortement
oui merci Madame le présidente monsieur
le rapporteur monsieur les sénateurs
une petite focale donc sur le champ
évidemment qui est complémentaire de ce
qu'on vient d'entendre sur la paille et
sur les industriels de l'isolation et
pour répondre d'emblée sur la
problématique de cet effet d'aubaine si
effectivement tous les marchés s'ouvrent
biosourcés est-ce qu'on est en capacité
nous filière de de suivant
22000 hectares de chanvre cultivés
aujourd'hui 180 000 hectares en France à
la fin du 19e siècle donc le la capacité
de progression est énorme qui plus est
cette plante n'est pas une plante
concurrente de la filière alimentaire
c'est ce qu'on appelle une tête
d'assolement donc à après le chanvre il
y a du blé et quand on plante du chanvre
même avec le bulleterre qui est en
conventionnelle ne met pas de Phyto dans
le champ il y a pas de phytosanitaire
dans le champ il y a pas de il y a pas
de de
traitement d'un train dans le champ
quand on plante du chanvre donc on
réduit les impacts intrant dans les
champs quand on parle du chanvre ça
c'est le premier aspect
construire en chambre et la filière
chambre de manière globale est une
filière simple à comprendre et c'est une
filière dite intégrée construire
ensemble travail main dans la main avec
un torchon qui est l'amant de la filière
qui s'occupe de tous les marchés sauf la
construction qu'on se rend chambre et
évidemment spécifique à la construction
elle a développé depuis une trentaine
d'années donc des règles
professionnelles qui permettent
d'accéder à tous les chantiers ces
règles professionnelles sont reconduites
cette année tout domaine d'emploi
confondu il y a pas de limitation de
hauteur et elle a développé un label
granulat c'est le seul label granulat
végétal disponible aujourd'hui en France
cette spécificité là elle est reconnue à
l'international nous accompagnons la
structuration de filière au Québec nous
accompagnons la structuration de filière
en Afrique australe et au Maroc pourquoi
parce que ces filières là n'ont pas
développé ce savoir-faire sur la
construction qui est spécifique à la
France donc autant utiliser ce
savoir-faire franco-français avec des
matériaux locaux des matériaux
effectivement en circuit court
nous aussi nous avons quelques
propositions qui sont complémentaires de
ce que vient de dire Olivier sur d'une
part l'adaptation de l'arsenal
réglementaire aujourd'hui toute la
rénovation énergétique est câblée sur le
lambda c'est à dire la réglementation
qui fixe l'évacuation de la chaleur de
l'intérieur du bâtiment vers l'extérieur
du bâtiment et bien il est aussi
possible de pondérer ce seul facteur
lambda par quelques critères assez
simple comme accepter des facteurs de
résistance thermique plus bas
pour les matériaux à pondération
supérieure à perméabilité supérieure ou
à inertie de chaleur d'été plus
importante c'est le cas de ces matériaux
biosourcés qui offrent effectivement
notamment de l'inertie à la chaleur
d'été importante voilà donc ça c'est une
c'est une indication c'est une
proposition et puis c'est intégré dans
la réfonte en cours des labels bâtiments
biosourcés un chapitre rénovation qui
bonifierait les cibles les aides à louer
des heures numérotation c'est sur le
domaine des dispositifs incitatifs
comme l'a dit Olivier effectivement il
faut sortir de la rénovation énergétique
monogestes pour aller plutôt vers une
logique de rénovation environnementale
donc vous avez effectivement un
dispositif qui s'appelle prime rénov
sérénité qui permet de globaliser l'acte
les rénovation mais elle est très peu
mobilisée c'est 60 000 dossiers
seulement selon la nappe qui est jugé
trop complexe à mettre en place et
surtout dans ma tâche administratif et
financier kafkaïen donc comment peut-on
aborder effectivement une rénovation
environnementale simple pour accompagner
les ménages ça passe par le fait
d'inclure les honoraires
d'accompagnement des accompagnateurs
dans les aides à louer à la rénovation
de manière à pas laisser effectivement
les particuliers seuls à se démener avec
avec ses enjeux là et puis une troisième
axe c'est accompagner sur la durée ce
qu'on appelle la boîte à outils et là
nous sollicitons d'encourager l'effort
de la formation à la transition
écologique à tous les niveaux de
formation initiale formation continue et
pour tous les acteurs les entreprises
qui sont peu voire pas du tout former
aux matériaux sourcés les bâtiments les
entreprises RGE les auditeurs
énergétiques les futurs accompagnateurs
primes rénov mais également les maîtres
d'ouvrages professionnels et pourquoi
pas les corps préfectoraux et les élus
voilà les enjeux selon nous de cette
rénovation énergétique
appliquée aux matériaux
oui merci madame la Présidente alors
pour compléter pour revenir un petit peu
aux enjeux de la de la rénovation on le
voit face à a été dit les solutions
biosourcées en fait elles sont très
diverses aujourd'hui
et la France est un peu spécifique par
rapport à ça puisqu'on a vraiment des
solutions entre la paille les béton
biosourcés les isolants des solutions
assez différentes et donc qui permettent
de répondre vraiment à l'enjeu de la
rénovation qui est on le sait est
important alors après derrière cet
enjeu-là on l'a vu avec la r2020 pour le
9 on a introduit une question du carbone
et ce qui a été très bien pour la pour
le pour le pour le 9 et dans la
réglementation c'était un point très
important parce que on a aussi en
parallèle à répondre à un enjeu de
stockage carbone pour répondre à la
stratégie nationale bas carbone donc
cette question du carbone qui a été qui
a été évoquée à plusieurs reprises elle
est très importante et aujourd'hui elle
n'apparaît pas dans le dans le dans la
rénovation enfant en tout cas dans le
dans le cadre réglementaire en lien avec
la rénovation
du carbone n'apparaît pas donc ça veut
dire qu'à un moment donné il va falloir
aussi l'introduire dans la rénovation
cette question du carbone et comment
produire dans la rénovation il y a
plusieurs façons de faire mais il faut
orienter les politiques publiques vers
les vers l'utilisation envers une
utilisation accrue des biosourcés on l'a
vu les industriels aujourd'hui sont sont
prêts à les capacités sont doublées là
actuellement pour répondre vous avez
évoqué 27 millions de mètres carrés en
2020 la capacité de la production va
passer à peu près à 60 millions de
mètres carrés dans les années à venir
donc il y a une réponse qui aujourd'hui
qui aujourd'hui prête mais maintenant la
rénovation énergétique il va falloir
orienter si on veut orienter
spécifiquement vers les vers des
matériaux biosourcés donc ça passe par
des C2 bonifiés par exemple on l'a
évoqué ça passe par un label Bâtiment
milieu source et rénovation puisque on
l'a dans le neuf ça permet au maître
d'ouvrage de s'approprier la question du
la question du biosourcer et de fixer
des objectifs à l'ensemble des acteurs
maîtrise d'oeuvre entreprise donc
ça serait effectivement très utile que
ce type de ce type de label soit mis en
place aussi pour la pour la rénovation
et là il y a des choses qui sont qui
sont quasiment prêtes il y a des il y a
déjà des il y a déjà eu des réflexions
sur le sur le sujet donc le label la TVA
réduite ça a été aussi évoqué donc tout
ce qui est un moment donné va
faciliter
l'intégration du biosourcé c'est en fait
faciliter l'intégration de la question
du carbone dans la rénovation
très bien monsieur le rapporteur
merci merci madame la Présidente merci
pour
déjà vous expliquer
non moi j'avais peut-être plusieurs
plusieurs questions d'abord sur le c'est
vrai que la commission d'enquête on
s'est penché sur l'ensemble des
politiques publiques depuis le Grenelle
pour essayer de voir à la fois ce qui
fonctionnait ce qui fonctionnait pas et
puis l'ensemble de l'évolution en fait
de ces politiques publiques et on voit
qu'on a eu un certain nombre de
modifications et puis là on arrive voilà
avec ma prime rénov vous avez un petit
peu parlé à quelque chose qui
on commence un petit peu à deviner
comment tout ça pourrait pourrait
fonctionner savoir si vous avez été
associé en fait justement à ces
différentes étapes et assez différentes
modifications dans la mise en place de
ces politiques de rénovation thermique
avec des
ambitions assez fortes mais voilà du
coup et pas et de la même manière sur le
sur le DPE vous avez un petit peu parlé
chacun justement des problématiques
qu'on pouvait avoir sur l'intégration du
biosourcer dans les calculs thermiques
avec la question du lambda enfin en tout
cas de comment on intègre la question
des biosourcés et que pas sur un seul
angle et notamment le lien aussi au
confort d'été en tout cas tout ce qui
peut être inertie etc
et donc savoir si aussi vous avez été
associé du coup dans la modification du
DPE et éventuellement l'intégration
justement de d'autres critères qui
permettraient de mieux favoriser en tout
cas de de mieux cibler les matériaux
biosourcés
[Musique]
intéressant et qui du coup dans lequel
vous pourriez vous vous inscrire en lien
avec ça mais vous en avez un peu parlé
la question des normes avis technique
assurance
on sait que c'est toujours une
problématique en tout cas que ce soit un
marché public ou autre d'ailleurs sur
l'utilisation de de matériaux biosourcés
quand on parle de la paille ou de voilà
qui sont
moins normé on va dire que d'autres
matériaux et puis avec des groupes moins
importants derrière donc cette
difficulté là
sur stockage du carbone vous en avez
parlé c'était peut-être sur le comment
en fait parce qu'on a souvent parlé de
la rémunération justement de ce stockage
de carbone quoi puisque c'est vrai que
avec le biosourcé ça permet du coup de
pouvoir stocker le carbone pendant voilà
on sait que maintenant le carbone a une
valeur et donc comment vous imaginez en
fait le retour de cette valeur que ce
soit auprès des entreprises ou que ce
soit auprès des agriculteurs et de voir
quel cheminement en fait quel mécanisme
on pourrait mettre en place
et puis une autre question oui c'était
sur l'autre l'autoconstruction
on s'aperçoit quand même on a eu aussi
pas mal dans d'autres auditions nous a
parlé de
l'autoconstruction et c'est vrai qu'on
voit que en autoconstruction
naturellement on va dire on utilise
beaucoup plus des matériaux à la fois
locaux et matériaux biosourcés donc
c'est vrai que c'est directement aussi
adapté que ce soit pas échange etc
et donc voilà du coup est-ce que
vous avez aussi des idées sur
l'encadrement en tout cas de ces
chantiers d'auto-construction parce que
ce qu'on s'aperçoit aussi c'est
actuellement avec le fonctionnement
d'aide tel qu'il est fait quelqu'un qui
va auto-construire qui va rester chez
matériaux en fait il passe à côté de
l'ensemble des aides et voilà et donc du
coup il est plutôt plutôt pénalisé
et puis pour terminer peut-être la place
de la compagnateur Renov en fait comment
pareil vous l'imaginez puisque c'est
vrai que ça peut être intéressant
justement sur l'accompagnement sur
l'accompagnement sur sur une rénovation
globale mais donc ça veut dire aussi
formation etc pour aussi orienter sur
des matériaux biosourcés donc en fait
comment comment vous l'imaginez vous le
voyez vous l'intégrer dans la
dans la dans la chaîne
voilà pas mal
première question donc c'était sur
est-ce qu'on a été associé aux
réflexions sur la rénovation en général
et tout ce qui est DPE évolutions vous
remercie beaucoup de nos auditionner ça
permet justement de parler de des
saisons jeux concrètement non on est on
est peu associé même pour cette raison
qu'on a créé des associations de façon à
être représentée au niveau national
c'est une industrie qui a 15 ans
qu'on se prend en charge à peu près la
même période et donc on s'est dit
comment se rassembler de façon à porter
des projets communs notamment sur la
réglementation et comment faire évoluer
l'alimentation donc la RT 2012 on est
arrivé on la subit il a été décidé
longtemps avant et l'aéro 2020 en tout
cas on a pu participer donc c'est une
bonne chose mais sur la rénovation on
voit que c'est un grand chantier alors
quand je dis on n'est pas associé on est
associé dans certaines réflexions mais
en tout cas on souhaite demain
association qu'on connaît une autre qui
sont vraiment dans le lieu sourcé soit
systématiquement pris en compte parce
que évidemment on n'est pas aussi
représentatif même si aujourd'hui on
fait 10% l'isolation d'isolation en
général par rapport aux gros acteurs de
structurer etc on a moins de poids moins
d'actions possibles par rapport
évidemment à nos capacités aussi de
disponibilité donc c'est un des enjeux
parce que je pense que là-dessus
évidemment des idées à apporter voilà
pour la réponse à la première question
rémunération de stockage cabane je peux
en parler moi parce que moi je travaille
dans une coopérative de récolte donc on
produit du chant
pour un certain acteur notamment
Philippe sur ses projets
c'est vrai que c'est un des enjeux parce
que aujourd'hui rien ne permet de
récupérer ce carbone qu'on stocke qui
est important sur le champ on dit c'est
l'équivalent de 15 tonnes de CO2 à
l'hectare c'est l'équivalent de la forêt
et ça renouvelable chaque année
donc j'en profite aussi pour vous dire
et Philippe l'a dit aucunement en tout
cas à son concurrence avec
l'alimentation puisque chanvre on peut
produire du chènevis le récolter pour
alimenter et c'est un coproduit la
paille et en plus c'est une excellente
tête de rotation donc ça a été dit donc
il y a souvent des travailleurs
détracteurs par rapport à ça mais c'est
un faux débat et demain il y a pas que
le champ avec le tueur a d'autres
potentiels la paille en fait partie donc
ça évidemment c'est pas une question
mais en tout cas sur le carbone c'est
vrai que ça des enjeux comment les
rémunérer c'est parfois des productions
pour agriculteurs qui sont moins
internes intéressantes à court terme que
de faire un blé ou qui a un cours
mondial qui est connu donc ils le font
parce qu'il y a un intérêt pour leur
production agricole pour la rotation des
sols l'enzolifto sanitaires etc par
contre le carbone est parmi aujourd'hui
puisque il y a la belle bas carbone dans
la culture mais c'est sur l'amélioration
du stockage carbone du bilan carbone
exploitation et on valorise pas ce
carbone qui est stocké dans le bâtiment
et c'est dommage parce qu'aujourd'hui il
y a aucun texte pas mal de le faire donc
ça pourrait être un carbone volontaire
stockage carbone ou enfin une
valorisation avec des des pas des
obligés mais du coup à des acteurs qui
volontairement vont payer ce carbone
stocké mais bon aujourd'hui à défaut de
textes c'est difficile à mettre en œuvre
et je pense que c'est un des enjeux si
demain il y avait des solutions
réglementaires pour le faire ça sera
évidemment une bonne chose
merci Olivier donc petite nuance sur
effectivement est-ce qu'on est associé à
tout ce qui se passe au niveau
réglementaire oui et non
le texte le réglementaire se fait avec
nous sans nous ou contre nous
effectivement on est souvent pris dans
les fourches cliniques de cette
réglementation qui s'applique pour
autant on a été consulté et on a
participé aux travaux du CNR logement et
on a participé effectivement à
l'audition de Guy ascoet qui a remis son
rapport qui n'est pas encore publié mais
qui a été remis
au Ministre du Logement qui fait je
pense la part belle sur C ensuite sur la
mastification des solutions
industrielles de type ise c'est à dire
isolation par l'extérieur toute la
filière s'organise pour donc je
représente un fabricant de solutions
béton de champ on pourrait fabriquer et
la filière est déposée France 2030
spécifique sur les ite nous sommes au
mois de mai prochain par la dame sur ce
cet enjeu là c'est un gros dossier à
hauteur d'un million d'euros pour la
filière c'est beaucoup qui va permettre
effectivement de
d'aller vers la massification de ces
solutions puisque comme pour la paille
l'essentiel de ce qui nous régente les
règles professionnelles ont été écrites
sur le 9 et pas du tout sur la
rénovation énergétique donc on a ce ce
cap à passer ensemble et sur pour finir
la formation effectivement des
accompagnateurs primes rénov il est
indispensable sinon qu'il soit formé en
tout cas ce qu'il soit sensibilisé au
matériaux biosourcés voilà c'est pas du
tout le cas aujourd'hui voilà
sur le stockage carbone et bien oui il
faudrait que ce se cache à carbone s'il
est valorisé il revient à l'agriculteur
et non pas à l'opérateur en bout de
course et notamment le promoteur
immobilier voilà c'est un enjeu
considérable pour stabiliser
effectivement cette production chambre
moi je reviens juste sur le les normes
dans la construction en paille pour
information donc on a déposé nous des
règles professionnelles qui ont été
validées en 2012 donc ça fait maintenant
plus de 10 ans c'est ça qui a permis
quand même que ce que ça se développe au
niveau au niveau français
mais même et on va jusqu'à du R + des
danses professionnelles mais on voit que
les gens ont envie d'aller plus loin on
a aujourd'hui des bâtiments qui vont
jusqu'à du r+9 isolé en paille et en ite
on a aussi de nombreux exemples
notamment des HLM on a plusieurs
bailleurs sociaux qui ont envie vraiment
d'aller vers ça notamment par rapport à
la préfabrication on a plus de la moitié
des gens qui construisent en paille
aujourd'hui qui font de la
préfabrication donc des caissons avec de
la paille dedans la paille sous
différentes formes d'ailleurs avant ce
cantonais à la botte de paille
aujourd'hui la paille hachée se
développe donc c'est en gros ça la même
chose que bottes de paille mais on
enlève les ficelles et il y a la même
densité et puis on a aussi les
botafaçons donc des bottes avec des
dimensions particulières donc on peut
commander chez j'ai des gens qui
fabriquent ces bottes exprès donc on
voit que le marché se développe et que
et qu'aujourd'hui il y a une forte
demande donc on a plusieurs exemples à
Paris de HLM isolé en Ito en paille à
Grenoble aussi on a un projet en R+7 et
r+9 avec l'OPAC 38 qui enfin
anciennement appelé au pack 38 qui qui a
envie développer ça donc on voit quand
même qu'il y a une envie il y a une
envie d'aller vers voilà une isolation
forte pour diminuer aussi l'impact des
coûts énergétiques de chauffage pour
pour ces populations qui peuvent tout
simplement difficilement payer leur
chauffage donc s'ils n'ont pas à payer
c'est quand même un gros avantage et on
a vu dans les retours des bâtiments HLM
qui étaient isolés bien isolée alors que
soit en paille ou autre chose c'est que
souvent on avait beaucoup moins de
rotation les locataires partaient moins
de chez eux parce que justement ils
avaient une rénovation et finalement ça
permettait de faire des grosses
économies pour les bailleurs sociaux et
même quand les charges étaient encore
plus réduites finalement ça revenait
plus cher de leur envoyer leurs factures
que de faire charge gratuite pour tous
les locataires donc on voit qu'elle est
loin et fort c'est quand même assez
important
on parlait de d'isoler par quartier moi
je dirais aussi par type de bâtiment
c'est à dire que si on a dans un
quartier du bâtiments type année 70 ça
vaut le coup de travailler sur ces 10
bâtiments qui vont avoir très
certainement la même solution
constructive et donc là on fait des
économies d'échelle pour se dire que on
va utiliser tel ou tel matériau que ce
soit de la paille ou un autre matériau
mais en tout cas dans certains cas la
pas est possible c'est pas toujours la
meilleure solution mais en tout cas je
pense que ça peut être intéressant de
réfléchir comme ça également
pour ce qui est de l'autoconstruction
donc nous on a une bonne connaissance de
ça parce que la construction en paille a
démarré avec des autoconstructeurs
c'est important d'intégrer ces gens là
qui ont envie de faire des travaux de
rénovation chez eux parce qu'ils sont
nombreux parce que notamment quand on
est à la campagne on sait bricolé par
contre parfois on connaît pas tous les
impacts que l'on peut faire et notamment
il y a des problématiques de diffusion
de vapeur d'eau etc qui pourrait nuire
au bâtiment donc je pense que
l'auto-corption est à valorisée mais a
aussi à accompagner avec des
professionnels compétents et c'est
intéressant de se dire que peut-être sur
un type de travaux si on veut faire une
isolation par l'extérieur on laisse
faire toute la partie j'en sais rien
jusqu'à la lame d'air par un
professionnel et le bardage peut être
peut-être posé par un autoconstructeur
on n'est pas obligé de faire tout noir
ou tout blanc mais en tout cas c'est
important d'orienter les gens vers oui
c'est possible peut-être pas partout ou
peut-être accompagné
ce que je voulais aussi rappeler c'est
que on a quand même un rôle assez
intéressant au niveau des BIOS sourcils
au niveau européen et même même plus
loin on est quand même très avancé par
rapport aux autres pays on a en France
on est on a plus de bâtiments en paille
que tous les autres pays européens
réunis donc on a eu un projet européen
là qui vient se terminer qui s'appelle
obstro avec 6 ou 7 pays on était leader
de ce programme là et on a on est
vraiment regardé par les autres pays et
on est aussi pris en exemple par exemple
nos règles professionnels là qu'on a
écrit en qu'on a sorti en 2012 elles ont
été traduites déjà en espagnol en
anglais en italien donc on voit que on
peut aussi donner une impulsion pour les
autres pays pour monter que c'est
possible et du chanvre de la paille du
bois il y en a dans tous les pays et
donc c'est vraiment quelque chose
à faire diffuser et à montrer à plus
grande échelle également
le stage vous pouvez rajouter quelque
chose juste deux petits mots par rapport
à l'avocat au cadre réglementaire
effectivement pour la pour la pour le
neuf on avait été sollicité donc on a
participé et on a pu défendre cette
question du carbone pour le la
rénovation si toutefois une
réglementation se mettait en place et
finalement ce serait important que les
filières du sourcier puisse participer
mais au-delà du cadre réglementaire il y
a tout le cadre normatif qu'on a évoqué
le cadre des avis techniques alors on
est on est favorable évidemment à
rentrer dans ce cadre là parce que c'est
c'est ce qui garantit la qualité des des
bâtiments et des ouvrages donc il faut
rentrer dans ce cadre là toutefois ce
qu'on constate c'est que on a
aujourd'hui un peu une surenchère sur
les exigences qui sont qui sont
demandées et notamment aux biosourcés
dans les dossiers d'instruction que ce
soit les dossiers d'avis techniques et
autres donc
on a du mal à expliquer et donc parfois
difficile à lever donc ça c'est ça c'est
un point important donc c'est pas du
cadre réglementaire mais c'est le cadre
normatif qui peut freiner aussi le le
développement de la de la filière
et puis sur juste sur le dernier point
sur le la place de la compagnateur Renov
ou c'est très important effectivement
qui est cet accompagnement là
nous on est plutôt favorable à ce qui
est un maître d'oeuvre qui qui suivent
ces travaux là donc avec la compétence
alors la compétence évidemment sur le
biosourcée mais lorsqu'on est en
rénovation il n'y a pas que le
biosourcer puisqu'on part d'un bâtiment
existant donc il y a la connaissance de
l'existant donc c'est c'est quelqu'un
qui est la compétence biosourcée mais
qui va c'est une compétence qui va bien
au-delà qu'elle a compétence du bâtiment
et de et de la rénovation qui est une
compétence très très particulière
avec une obligation de résultat oui ça
pourrait être ça pourrait être important
est-ce que vous avez d'autres questions
ou est-ce que nos collègues souhaitent
poser des questions oui Franck montoger
c'est madame la Présidente pour vos
présentations j'aurais deux questions
donc une de clarification en tout cas
pour ce qui me concerne moi j'ai compris
que le alors je souscris tout à fait
à la nécessité à à
la logique de rémunérer les agriculteurs
pour les prestations de services
environnementaux dont
celui que que vous évoquez mais moi j'ai
compris quand même que le pourquoi on se
comprenne bien que que le stockage de
carbone il se faisait au champ
il se fait il se fait pas dans la dans
la dans la structure
d'habitat on est bien d'accord
c'est ça il se fait l'exploitation
il se fait à l'exploitation voilà
donc en fait quand on compare par
rapport à ce critère les matériaux de
construction on les compare par rapport
à la phase d'élaboration de ces de ces
matériaux là on est bien d'accord on
prend le stockage carbone lié à la
matière première puisque les matières
premières à la matière première et au
processus et au processus de fabrication
tout à fait là mais une fois qu'on est
sur le
sur la construction elle-même la
fonction de stockage voilà
elle n'est pas du même ordre que c'est
le qu'on peut trouver au champ ou voilà
pour ce qui concerne les matériaux
biosourcés on est d'accord hein on
décale quelque part en stockant du
carbone dans un bâtiment on décale le
fait de rejeter du carbone par exemple
si ça revient en litière bah du coup on
redégrade la matière carbone et elle va
repartir dans un champ etc donc hop elle
est partie alors que nous on décale
pendant 50 100 ans la durée de
l'isolation ce stockage du carbone donc
on déplace le problème certes mais on
espère que dans son temps on aura un peu
un petit peu avancé donc on décale cette
problématique de carbone a dans une
centaine d'années
c'est le cas c'est le cas pour la
filière paille mais pour la filière
chambre on a fait les tests avec le CSTB
nos matériaux sont entièrement
recyclables donc on a séquestré ce
carbone qui est au champ certes on la
séquestré pendant la durée de vie du
bâtiment et notre ACV il est de 100 ans
il est pas de 50 ans donc on a une durée
de vie exceptionnelle et en bout de
cycle on peut recycler l'intégralité de
nos produits l'intégralité
sauf que la petite nuance c'est
qu'aujourd'hui la fin de la F2S dont
vous parle sur le produit le process on
prend en compte également la fin de vie
des matériaux donc aujourd'hui on est
pénalisé alors qu'on a l'avantage
puisqu'on considère qu'à la fin de vie
il va décarboner parce qu'on connaît pas
sa fin de vie aujourd'hui même si nous
on sait que demain on pourra le recycler
peut-être dans 60 ans l'enjeu de la
planète sera plus le carbone sera
peut-être au sujet on aura peut-être
moins d'émissions mais aujourd'hui en
tout cas on est pénalisé puisqu'on
considère que le carbone qu'on a stocké
il va être déstocké en fin de vie ce qui
est pas très juste dans l'analyse et
malheureusement du coup on valorise à
aucun moment ce stockage carbone
je suis d'accord avec vous sur la
nécessité de le valoriser il y a pas de
mais voilà je voulais me faire presser
les choses je vous remercie de vous
répondre deuxième petite question vous
avez évoqué la je crois que c'est vous
madame la problématique de la
certification
des produits c'est vous je crois voilà
donc moi j'aurai une question je dirais
complémentaire au subsidiaire par
rapport à cette thématique de la
certification c'est la question de
l'acceptation de ces matériaux par les
assurances
que vous qui n'a pas été évoqué est-ce
que est-ce que ce peut-être pas un sujet
si c'est pas si c'est pas un sujet tant
mieux mais est-ce que est-ce que
éventuellement ça n'est un quoi alors
les règles professionnelles qu'on a
écrit à 10 ans ont permis elles
permettent justement d'avoir accès à une
assurance décennale pour les entreprises
ça a été ce qui a permis de lever
vraiment ce qui coinçait à l'époque donc
ça ça a aidé par contre comme on vous
l'a dit c'est surtout sur le neuf
aujourd'hui qu'on les a écrites donc
c'est vrai que sur l'isolation par
l'extérieur et la rénovation il faudrait
continuer ce travail moi c'est mon
travail actuellement je suis en train de
développer ça mais c'est vrai qu'on a
peu de moyens on a un peu des aides de
l'ADEME mais c'est quand même un gros
travail donc il faut qu'on avance encore
à travers des règles pro être avec des
avis techniques enfin il y a différentes
façons d'avancer vers ça pour lever ces
blocages là mais c'est en bonne voie
après je pense qu'il faut quand même
continuer à à nous soutenir pour que on
développe davantage de solutions
pertinente quoi d'accord oui si je reste
quand même un petit sujet quoi oui oui
quand même oui ça reste toujours
effectivement un sujet parce qu'il y a
effectivement des produits nouveaux qui
se développent donc il faut les faire
rentrer dans le cadre normatif pour
qu'il devienne des techniques courantes
et pour qu'il soit considéré comme des
par les assureurs comme des techniques
courantes et donc bénéficiant de
décennales etc etc donc il y a toujours
du travail à faire dès lors ou en plus
on innove avec ces avec ces matériaux là
par contre ce qu'on peut dire
considérait pas comme un frein quand
même la situation alors aujourd'hui on
peut fabriquer construire un bâtiment
dans un cadre sécurisé reconnu par les
assurances avec les produits qui
existent on l'a dit il y a des règles
professionnelles il y a des avis
techniques donc aujourd'hui des
solutions existent pour construire et
pour rénover avec les produits
biosourcés dans un cadre sécurisé par
contre comme derrière le MBU sourcés il
y a aussi l'innovation mais il faut
toujours évidemment travailler sur ces
sujets pour les nouveaux produits qui
vont se développer
il y a notamment les les bâtiments r+3+4
parfois il y a des contraintes feux et
là il y a des solutions sauf que c'est
des gros travaux à menés pour passer ces
étapes de tests qui permet la
certification et c'est là pour des
filières qui sont des filières jeunes
c'est des coûts qui sont énormes
soutenir ces filières pour qu'ils
puissent investir parce que s'il y a pas
de marché c'est difficile d'investir se
découvre qui sont souvent difficiles à
supporter quoi
j'avais une troisième et dernière
question
alors qui est un peu en marge du sujet
de la commission d'enquête puisque la
question porte sur le la construction
neuve mais du point de vue de la
rentabilité et du modèle économique de
vos de vos filières voilà
on peut construire avec de la terre crue
un ni mélangeant éventuellement de la
paille etc est-ce que
d'abord est-ce que ce que est-ce que ce
que je dis correspond à une réalité mais
ça me le que oui et et
est-ce que
la problématique de la construction
neuve avec utilisant donc des matériaux
biosourcés peut avoir des conséquences
je dirais positives favorable sur
l'ensemble de vos activités rénovation
énergétique d'un côté et construction
neuve de l'autre
à partir de matériaux encore une fois
biosourcés vous voyez le sens de mon
propos oui je vais commencer une réponse
et puis Olivier tu poursuivra grâce à la
loi résilience 2025 grâce à l'aéro du
2020 nous avons ouvert une usine que le
sénateur compta qui s'appelle wallop qui
est la première usine au monde à faire
de la préfabrication béton de chanvre
voilà c'est parce que le marché
s'ouvrait que nous avons pu
effectivement industrialiser le
territoire donc c'est en Île-de-France
c'est avec un circuit court reste la
question effectivement de la rentabilité
initiale pour l'agriculteur aujourd'hui
le cours du chanvre trop bas par rapport
à l'inflation du cours du blé et
d'autres produits et donc la
rémunération en amont pour l'agriculteur
est pas suffisante pour qu'il y ait une
explosion effectivement de de mise en
culture sur le marché
et donc la solution en revient à cette
question c'est l'enjeu du stockage
carbone et de la rémunération de ce
stockage carbone au champ
oui majeur Majeur en tout cas ce qu'on
peut voir et on voit que la partie en
effet réglementation lorsque l'état
donne un signe on voit que ça ça
fonctionne l'aéro 2020 on peut vous dire
on l'a vu ça a été un effet quand même
d'accélérateur pour les sourcer dans le
9 ça c'est une réalité aujourd'hui même
tous les grands industriels qui étaient
pas dans les matériaux sourcés s'y met
aujourd'hui parce que l'enjeu de
stockage carbone qui va monter l'indice
carbone ça les trois indicateurs la R20
qui va être de plus en plus dur à
atteindre forcément ça transforme les
industries donc c'est quelque chose de
positif donc c'est vrai que sur la
rénovation
il a signaler c'est un des enjeux
majeurs il faudrait pas que la
rénovation ou qui est quand même l'un
des enjeux majeurs de mains parce qu'on
sait que sont foncier ils vont manquer
donc c'est la rénovation il y a beaucoup
à faire au moins utiliser les bâti
existants là si on met pas en compte les
mêmes cris enfin les critères
équivalents sur le carbone on passera à
côté d'un enjeu majeur qui peut en plus
soutenir de façon très forte les matos
de sourcée un coin un vrai intérêt pour
tous on sait même l'agriculture peuvent
évoluer la fois aussi mais l'agriculture
vous savez on peut faire rigoler
génétique pour avoir plus de biomasse au
champ donc de paille ça c'est possible
c'est demain il y a une valorisation
possible donc il y a un vrai potentiel
pour la filière française en France en
général
le prix de carbone est une question à la
fois très compliquée mais fondamentale
dans ses affaires là et pas que celle-là
d'ailleurs
merci
Sabine dragster sur les enjeux
patrimoniaux très certainement non pas
toujours voilà alors en fait j'aimerais
savoir qu'est-ce qui explique selon vous
que les points bloquants par rapport à
l'utilisation de matériaux bio sourcé
comme le fait de ne pas être
associé à l'élaboration des politiques
publiques l'assuenchère par rapport aux
normes la complexité la longueur des
procédures de labellisation alors la la
reconnaissance de ses qualités en
matière de stockage carbone
pourquoi en fait ces points bloquants le
sont autant alors que tout le monde
plébiscite ce type de matériaux
qu'est-ce qu'il explique à votre avis
quand vous déposez un dossier prime
rénov mes parents l'ont fait d'abord ces
cavaliens pour accéder effectivement à
ses aides quand on coupe les aides et
ensuite encore une fois il n'y a que le
lambda qui valorise un matériau et donc
à coup comparé et bien on prend le
matériau le plus voilà que le
polyuréthane qui vient de Chine plutôt
que le matériau biosourcé qui un lambda
dégradé mais par contre qui embarque un
certain nombre de qualité
supplémentaires qui sont qui ne sont pas
pris dans le cadre réglementaire voilà
le
l'inertie la chaleur d'été l'hygroscopie
ça matériau qui respire le polyuréthane
le fait pas donc on crée la pathologie
de demain clairement on crée la
pathologie de demain
notamment sur le bâti patrimonial
exactement voilà on y revient
c'est ça
c'est comme les constructions empisées
où on a vu les enduitements qui tombent
régulièrement ça ça en gros c'est à peu
près le même problème on vient fermer
la vapeur d'eau qui est censée s'évacuer
par les parois avec des matériaux
manufacturés on vient les fermer donc
c'est sûr que c'est compliqué
mais c'est vrai que quand on veut se
lancer dans un projet de rénovation ce
que je disais tout à l'heure à mes
collègues font au moins avoir un bac + 3
ou un bac + 5 pour pouvoir suivre le
dossier donc déjà il faut être
propriétaire parce que clairement quand
on est locataire notre propriétaire
vient pas souvent nous aider à payer
notre facture de chauffage ou à la
diminué ensuite quand on est
propriétaire faut avoir un petit peu de
sous de côté pour au moins autofinancer
une partie
et ensuite pouvoir même si on a des sous
pouvoir gérer le dossier et comprendre
les enjeux parce que bah c'est pas
simple quand on a un bâtiment
patrimonial ou pas quand on vient nous
dire non mais c'est bon la polystyrène
il n'y a pas de souci ça a fonctionné
comment on sait comment on renseigne
tout alors on a il y a quand même des
agences qui sont là pour aider
mais tout le monde n'est pas formé à
tout ça et puis clairement bah le voilà
le coup il y a un moment c'est souvent
moins cher parce que ça va plus vite
parce que clairement dans 20 ans il
faudra l'enlever donc voilà les gens
vont vite là où ils peuvent s'ils le
peuvent
je me permets d'intervenir en plus il y
a le sujet de la compétitivité qu'on n'a
pas abordé qui est un sujet ça va être
quelqu'un qui construit ou qui rénove il
se pose la question du coup des
matériaux
alors il y a quelques années l'écart
entre les matos de sourcés les mathothée
du soleil étaient assez élevées enfin en
tout cas il y avait un écart souvent de
25 30 %, ça c'est fortement réduit parce
que on a industrialisé même si ils sont
pas du niveau de massification de
l'industrie traditionnelle qui est
encore à notre niveau et forcément ça
juste sur les coûts les prix de revient
mais l'écart c'est quand même évidemment
réduit c'est pour cette raison on sait
que le prix est quand même souvent
déterminant l'enjeu d'une TVA taux
réduit sur les rénovation et la
rénovation au sexe c'est quand même des
coûts assez élevés qu'on maîtrise
parfois un peu moins que le neuf et pour
le connaître et parfois des surprises
sur la rénovation je pense c'est quand
même à des vrais enjeux quoi je pense
que ça justifie d'une TVA réduite qui
permettrait de gommer le petit écart
qu'on peut avoir la formation des
artisans parce que les formations des
artisans vous savez ce sont les
industriels actuels qui sont des PME qui
sont amenés à les former donc tout ça
bah faut le financer je pense ce serait
un bon moyen d'accélérer et de répondre
à l'enjeu dont vous parlez
[Musique]
sur le 9 c'est ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui
on peut même dire par rapport aux enjeux
de l'énergie on a connu là un coût
énergétique de production très fort
certains industries étaient très
gourmand énergie augmentée bien plus
fortement leur prix que nous l'avons
fait sur le matériau parce qu'on est peu
gourmand en énergie et ça ça a permis de
réduire aussi les coûts alors c'est
peut-être conjoncturel puisque l'énergie
rebelle ça va aujourd'hui mais bon dans
la durée on peut se projeter
l'enjeu c'est évidemment des coûts de
production plus faibles mais voilà je
pense que aujourd'hui c'est entre on va
dire entre 5 et 12% on a l'exemple sur
7% sur du neuf bon je pense que la
vérité elle a 10% sans doute c'est le
retour qu'on a sur beaucoup de matériaux
ça dépend si certains matériaux sont
vraiment une phase industrielle très
importante si on parle des isolants par
exemple la famille d'isolants c'est le
surcoût qu'on a aujourd'hui à peu près
par rapport des matériaux dit
traditionnels après sur les matériaux
plus béton végétaux les carpes les plus
importantes parce que c'est moins
industrialisé même si l'entreprise
wall-up dont parlait Philippe a commencé
à pré-industrialiser et la
préfabrication industrielle c'est
évidemment l'avenir
posez vos pieds si je peux me permettre
le Président vous évoquez le programme
européen qui a démarré en 2017 2017 de
fin autorisé en 2017 et démarrer alors
programme européen un projet à plusieurs
pays pro ça date de 2016 peut-être 2015
je sais plus trop
après c'était c'était plus pour tirer
vers le haut les autres pays et avancer
ensemble parce que on est quand même pas
on part pas avec les mêmes bases
[Musique]
dans le calcul final quoi en fait et
dans le l'augmentation de leur
performances liées au DPE de leur
bâtiments donc je pense ça c'est un
élément important et donc comment vous
voyez en fait l'intégration parce qu'on
voit bien que le lambda classique il
fonctionne pas et j'avais été je crois
que c'était une étude plus je crois que
c'était le CSTB qui avait fait ça sur le
fait des petites boîtes
si et béton paille voilà et où on
s'aperçoit qu'en fait la sensation en
tout cas de confort elle est très
différente en fonction des matériaux
et que on va mettre le chauffage à 25
degrés quand on est dans une boîte à
métal et que on va le mettre à 17 18
degrés quand on est dans une boîte en
paille dans une boîte en chambre donc
cet aspect là de confort il est hyper
important parce que les trois quatre
degrés qu'on peut gagner en termes
d'économie d'énergie derrière ils sont
ils sont énormes
comment du coup on peut arriver à
l'intégrer pour faire en sorte que cet
aspect là soit pris en compte alors
peut-être un petit peu moins dans la
rénovation puisque peut-être plus dans
neuf mais mais quand même enfin je veux
dire même quand on donc cet aspect là il
me paraît il me paraît
particulièrement important et évidemment
s'il dépe ne le tient pas en compte
derrière on va on va forcément avoir des
problèmes quoi enfin en tout cas on va
pas favoriser ce type de matériaux
c'est un projet qu'on avait eu en commun
avec plusieurs filières biosourcés
d'ailleurs d'essayer d'avancer sur ce
sacro-sainte lambda qui est censé tout
caractériser sur l'énergie
c'est une question qui est compliquée
quand même parce que c'est très
technique en effet certains le STB et
d'autres s'ils sont frottés ça pas été
une question simple ça l'est toujours
pas on se rend compte en tout cas qui a
plein d'autres paramètres qu'il faut
prendre en compte pour identifier le
confort et en effet ça c'est quelque
chose de bien connu en physique
s'appelle la symétrie de rayonnement
donc quand on a des murs qui rayonnent
du froid on a beau chauffé à 25 on peut
avoir les mains froides et quand même
transpiré donc c'est quelque chose dans
certains bâtiments qui est pas
confortable donc il faut en effet
avancer là-dessus comment sur l'intégrer
au DPE je pense qu'il faudrait avancer
sur une sorte de lambda équivalent ou en
tout cas essayer d'avoir un lambda pour
les matériaux sourciers qui en ont qui
en ont besoin qui soit calculés en
fonction de leur caractéristique propre
dans les bétons végétaux ça peut être
justement l'inertie la vapeur d'eau qui
est utilisée dans la paille c'est ou
dans même la fibre de bois ça peut être
la densité du matériau parce qu'on voit
que les lambdas en réalité
sur le papier sont censés être très bons
mais dans la réalité quand ils sont
posés par les artisans on prend un
rouleau de laine X ou Y légère en tout
cas on le pose et si c'est trop léger la
problématique c'est que si on a une
mauvaise étanchéité à l'air ce qui se
fait encore et ben le pouvoir isolant
est vraiment très dégradé et sur des
matériaux qui sont plus denses comme ils
sont plus denses on a quand même une
pouvoir isolant qui est meilleur donc ça
ça n'a rien à voir avec le lambda avec
le pouvoir du matériau mais finalement
la propriété du matériau à se tenir à
bloquer les fuites d'air parasites etc
donc tout ça comment le prendre en
compte on a essayé de travailler dessus
mais on n'a pas encore eu assez de
budget pour pouvoir analyser ça on
voulait faire justement des petites
boîtes pour pouvoir comparer et essayer
d'avoir un lambda déclaré on a travaillé
de serrer mat dessus avec des labos avec
le FCB à là dessus il faudrait continuer
à travailler là dessus et à pouvoir
l'intégrer je pense dans le DPE avec un
lambda équivalent quel terme dont on
pourrait trouver oui je peux compter
effectivement c'est un sujet
scientifique qui est complexe donc on a
un projet en cours sur le sujet donc
avec le FCBA le l'air map pour essayer
de caractériser un peu mieux les choses
mais on se rend compte que comme c'est
complexe il faut aller plus loin
c'est-à-dire que le projet en lui-même
ne suffit pas donc il y a deux aspects
derrière le lambda c'est le confort
d'hiver mais on a aussi le confort d'été
et et cette caractéristique là on la
prend pas quasiment pas du tout en
compte aujourd'hui et alors que c'est
une des caractéristiques et une des
spécificités différenciantes des
matériaux biosourcés pour plusieurs
raisons pour des raisons scientifiques
aussi capacité thermique meilleure plus
de matière plus de densité alors on
parlait du prix tout à l'heure mais dans
les bios sourcils on a plus de matière
globalement par rapport aux matériaux
conventionnels donc ce qui explique
aussi qu'on a une différence au niveau
du prix mais ça apporte des
caractéristiques techniques notamment
par rapport au confort d'été
intéressantes donc c'est ces éléments là
qui effectivement ne sont pas prises en
compte aujourd'hui et qui finalement
différencie les matériaux biosourcés des
matériaux plus plus conventionnels mais
après cette question là la question du
confort c'est pas uniquement évidemment
un lambda vous l'avez dit c'est beaucoup
plus complexe que ça et ça aujourd'hui
on le voit en discutant avec des gens
qui vivent dans des bâtiments biosourcés
ils ont un ressenti qui est différent
mais on n'arrive pas à le traduire
réglementairement et ce que disait
Coralie un lambda bonifié effectivement
ça pourrait être ça pourrait être une
solution mais il faut qu'on arrive à le
démontrer concrètement
donc on y travaille il y a un projet de
R&D en cours collectif pour prouver en
effet l'effet le l'hygrométrie qui
apporte un plus dans les matériaux alors
le problème c'est on voudrait le
modéliser un lambda ça c'est facile à
modéliser mais comment le modéliser
sachant que l'hygrométrie varie tous les
jours toute l'année et forcément ça va
jouer sur la performance des matériaux
avec un plus alors jamais un mois mais
ça peut être selon les périodes un effet
plus ou moins positif sur le lambda et
ça c'est difficile à mesurer même si il
y a eu beaucoup d'essais qui prouvent
qu'il se passe quelque chose mais ce que
c'est un plus 10 + 15 par rapport à
l'ombre d'un classique ça aujourd'hui on
n'a pas réussi à le modéliser même s'il
est travaux en cours et je pense que ça
va prendre un peu de temps
quand je vous écoute donc vous dites
qu'en fait vous n'avez pas suffisamment
de moyens pour pouvoir aller aussi loin
qu'il le faudrait et rapidement sur ces
questions je vous pose la question par
rapport à au patrimoine bâti qui est
actuellement je veux dire vraiment en
péril à cause de ce qui est en train de
se passer les DPE on a déjà des maisons
qui sont démolis qui sont isolées avec
des matériaux absolument inadaptés qui
vont entraîner sa destruction ou alors
sa banalisation au niveau français donc
là on est vraiment on est en train de de
d'évoquer un sujet je trouve qu'il y a
un caractère d'urgence l'attribution de
moyens supplémentaires à ce type de
travaux parce qu'on est en train de
d'aller vers une espèce de sa cage
patrimonial avec ce qui est en train de
se passer
oui parfaitement nous avons besoin de
ces moyens supplémentaires mais pour
autant il y a des systèmes simples à
mettre en place vous avez déjà la prime
rénove sérénité qui autorise depuis 2021
à déroger au dicta du lambda
si tenter que les matériaux ou la
composition globale du bâtiment
permettent de répondre à beaucoup de
dangereux et bien ça c'est ce que nous
attendons c'est à dire que on mette en
place une maîtrise d'oeuvre qui
accompagne effectivement les opérateurs
de tout acabit dans la rénovation pas
rénovation monogeste mais dans une
rénovation qui soit
avec une garantie de résultats
aussi un manque de moyens on va quand
même se le dire parce que les sujets de
R&D dont vous parlez c'est le sujet
complexe
industriellement nous on peut faire on
fait beaucoup de choses mais ces sujets
sur plusieurs années dans des chambres
d'essai qui vraiment sont trop chers
pour quel que soit les industriels donc
c'est le rôle du CSTB de ses acteurs
mais qui doivent aussi leur limite en
termes financière donc comment
accompagner justement toute cette
modélisation dont on parle et je crois
que il y a les vrais enjeux
d'accompagnement R&D même s'il y a déjà
qu'on accompagnement qui se fait on a on
a un sujet en cours mais ça reste des
petit enveloppe et on a une première
étape et on sait qu'il y en aura
d'autres derrière et si on pouvait être
accompagné ce sera évidemment un plus en
gros on sait qu'en pratique ça
fonctionne sur des bâtiments du bâti
ancien des béton végétaux chauds etc ça
fonctionne isoler en paille par
l'extérieur du pisé ça fonctionne ça ne
dégradera pas le bâti mais on n'arrive
pas à le prouver on n'arrive pas à pour
l'instant en tout cas on n'a pas assez
de moyens pour arriver à montrer que que
ça fonctionne parce que parce que c'est
compliqué le bâtiment on a de la vapeur
on a des habitants qui ouvrent les
fenêtres et on sait pas beaucoup moins
alors comment Simler tout ça c'est voilà
c'est c'est et l'humain et de la
physique et plein de choses qu'on
comprend pas aussi il faut quand même
l'avouer mais on sait que on sait que ça
fonctionne en pratique ça fait 100 ans
200 ans que que les bâtiments sont
isolés comme ça et même plus des
millénaires pour le torchier etc le
torchis c'est de la paille c'est de la
terre la chou on sait que ça fonctionne
mais maintenant on doit tout prouver
donc il faut qu'on y arrive enfin ce
serait un objectif ça ne veut pas dire
quoi Russie pas qu'on réussira pas
demain mais aujourd'hui les matériaux
sont caractérisés en usine les lambdas
c'est mesures en usine mais l'usine
matériaux coûte caractérison de vie ne
sait pas ce qui se passe forcément le
bâtiment et c'est la complexité d'un
bâtiment en une enveloppe qu'il faut
réussir à modéliser si je prends reprend
ce terme
et c'est pour ça qu'on souhaiterait
qu'il y a des tests in situ pour prouver
sur plusieurs années quand on dit test
in situ c'est prendre plusieurs maisons
avec des constructions des matériaux
différents pour voir quelle influence on
est matériaux sur l'amélioration du
confort ressenti par les usagers
aujourd'hui qui vit dans ces dans ces
maisons et c'est ça qu'il faut réussir à
développer mais c'est des coûts
évidemment énormes aujourd'hui dans les
laboratoires quand on vient faire des
tests pour nos matériaux on doit faire
des matériaux grands comme ça ou grands
comme ça enfin une botte de paille
comment recréer ce qui se passe dans une
boîte de paille dans le sujet mais c'est
un peu la même chose pour eux dans des
petits échantillons comme ça alors qu'on
fait des bâtiments qui font des milliers
de mètres carrés donc c'est cette
complexité qu'on a du mal à qu'on a des
milliers de bâtiments qu'on a nous-mêmes
mis des capteurs dedans etc et
à obtenir les chiffres les mesures et à
faire la démonstration sur du bâti
existant en prenant en considération que
les modes constructifs d'alors peuvent
interagir sur le même process
c'est-à-dire qu'à même process appliqué
sur un habitat fait en béton cellulaire
préfabriqué et
la même typologie de logements mais
réalisée sur une brique ou autre on va
pas avoir les mêmes résultats avec le
même matériau isolant si je comprends
bien ce que c'est ça et surtout en
laboratoire en laboratoire expertiser
j'allais dire à échelle
c'est qu'aujourd'hui on nous demande de
ça dans des petites boîtes et ça c'est
compliqué
donc il faut il faut faire des vrais
tests avec des vrais gens et des vrais
bâtiments
savoir si vous étiez en lien avec les
grands ateliers de L'Isle-d'Abeau
sur le donc du coup c'est un on est allé
c'est en Isère on est allé le visiter et
qui est en fait le je crois que c'est je
crois que c'est unique en France mais
c'est de regrouper à la fois
architecte entreprise artisans et
travailler justement sur sur des on va
dire des matériaux biosourcés de tout
type alors au départ c'était accès axé
sur toute la question de la terre mais
ils ont fait aussi pas mal d'essai avec
la paille avec avec le chanvre etc
et donc elle s'intéressant parce que ça
permet de mettre aussi sur sur la
formation et sur le lien entre artisans
recherche architecte et puis d'essayer
aussi trouver
normaliser un petit peu des des procédés
donc voilà en tout cas je pense que si
vous avez pas le lien ça sera
intéressant on les connaît bien
ce qui nous manque c'est pas
l'état nous accompagne que ce soit la
dhjp la dame est-ce qu'il nous manque
c'est un accompagnement plus réel voilà
un contrat d'objectif sur plusieurs
années où on dit voilà où on va là c'est
du coup par coup c'est tous les ans il
faut déposer un dossier tous les ans il
faut se recentionner on passe plus de
temps à l'administratif que développer
effectivement des techniques ou des
essais
écoutez s'il n'y a plus de questions
vous remercie très sincèrement et puis
on vous souhaite de continuer à
progresser en la matière et bonne fin de
journée à vous
merci